what's up everyone
welcome to program your mode
today i'm going to show you how you can
get your honda accord started if your
key fob dies
whether it be a dead battery or some
other issue i'm going to show you how i
can still get your cord started
we're going to be doing it on a 2021
accord here but we'll be the same on a
few different years
so i've taken the battery out of this
key fob to demonstrate
as you can see none of the buttons are
working if i try to start it as i
normally would
i'm gonna get a message here saying to
start
hold the remote in your start button
so we'll come over here you can see the
stop start button is flashing hold it
near it
then it'll go solid and you also hear a
little beep
and now you can just go ahead and start
it as you normally would so break
start button
and that's it
pretty simple
if you have any questions please let me
know if you could take a second to like
and subscribe it helps us out and i'd
appreciate it
thank you